Hello,
everyone.
I'm kind of just vibing to this music right now.
How am I feeling?
I'm feeling like...
4 out of 10.
Today I'm feeling a little...
That's so great.
But it's okay.
It's alright.
I've already turned down the music so much, but maybe a little bit more.
Yeah, I also didn't get a lot of sleep last night because...
Well, partially... Sorry, I read a comment and I usually read the comments out loud so that people know what I'm talking about.
I am... I... Yeah, I started some new medicine recently and it's been messing with me a bit.
And... Also, last night I didn't get a lot of sleep last night.
I woke up really early and I was like...
My brain was like...
Because I was thinking about so many things.
Um, so...
Yeah, but...
I got some stuff done today.
So, you know.
Too busy reading about hot liches in the area.
I'll tell you, that book was...
Well, I fell asleep.
I don't even think I made it to chapter 2.
But, um...
I woke up in the middle of the night...
To a steamy, spicy scene.
A spicy meatball.
I don't even think I want to talk about this book, you guys.
I...
I don't even think I want to talk about this book.
It's so...
Oh...
It's...
Too freaky?
No...
Did they bone?
Haha, get it?
Cause he's a skelly man.
So...
For those who want some context...
I sometimes listen to...
Romance novels because...
Usually they're very silly.
Right?
They're very...
Um...
Yes, please.
I lack context.
So...
I sometimes listen to these...
To these romance novels...
Before like bed or...
If I'm in the shower or something.
Just because I'm like...
These are...
So silly.
And, um...
So, my...
My app has now...
It recommends me like every...
Okay, here.
Let me just go through it a little bit.
Let me just go through my app a little bit.
To give you a...
Shed some light...
On...
Um...
Where I'm at here.
I almost listened to...
Stranded with the Kraken.
Hahaha.
Donating funds for me to a healthcare plant.
Thank you.
Thank you for the pink.
Please.
Don't go broke.
Um...
Let's see.
We've got matched to the Minotaur.
And I'll be okay.
I promise.
Just...
Uh...
I was mostly okay today.
And then...
I don't know.
Maybe because it's getting late.
But, um...
Uh...
The Orc from The Office.
Wintan for the Wolven King.
Gifted to the Gargoyles.
Um...
Snowed in with the Gargoyles.
There's a lot of books about Orcs.
I don't understand why.
Maybe because they're like so humanoid.
Like her Orc mate.
Or her Orc king.
Sworn to the Orc.
Hahaha.
I don't understand.
It's the Tusks.
Maybe.
Hahaha.
Um...
But last night, I listened to one.
That was called...
Love.
Laugh.
Lich.
Which someone made a great point.
They were like...
They couldn't name it.
Lich.
Laugh.
Love.
What?
What an absolute...
Fumble on their part.
Hahaha.
Love.
Laugh.
Lich.
Hahaha.
And, um...
Here, I'll read you the...
I'll read you the synopsis.
Actually, hold on.
Can I read you the synopsis of the Kraken one?
Because it was...
It was cracking me up.
And get it?
Hahaha.
Uh...
Let's see.
Oh, gosh.
The thought of you dating another man makes me want to punch through a wall.
You're magnetic.
That's quote.
End quote.
I signed up for the new...
Bone...
Dash...
R...
App...
For monster dating.
Thinking I'd get a fun one night stand out of the deal.
Instead, I'm now stranded at the hot Kraken's house.
Hahaha.
Oh, at Christmas.
Because of a massive snowstorm.
And what started as a very hot hookup.
Who knew...
And the...
Parentheses.
Who knew tentacles were so...
Dot, dot, dot.
Flexible.
End parentheses.
Now feels like so much more.
But surely it's too early to be talking about serious things like family and forever, isn't it?
Stranded with the Kraken is a long novella with a human heroine and a kraken.
Here's another thing that you'll...
Another pattern you'll hear about in these stories.
They're not just monsters.
They're shifters.
So...
Hahaha.
It's not...
I...
Hahaha.
So...
So they're...
They...
They are able to change into...
Into...
This other...
Because they gotta be human at some point.
I...
I guess.
You can't just love the Kraken.
Um...
A Kraken shifter hero who falls for each other hard and fast.
You'll love it if you enjoy monster romance series with low angst, happy endings, and tentacles...
But yeah, I've listened to Love Laugh Lich.
Um...
Which...
The Lich is...
His name is like...
Solven or something.
This is why reading and liking the...
Lussy Argonian maid is not weird.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
Also, thank you, Barb!
Thank you so much!
My friend told me about a flamingo one.
Flamingo?
Huh?
But, um...
Do you think at any point someone yells, release the Kraken?
Huh?
I sure hope so.
Oh my gosh!
I sure hope so!
Wait, how long was this one?
Cause I definitely woke up and it was like, we hope you enjoyed the book.
It's...
I can't tell.
It doesn't say.
I think each chapter is like 5 minutes.
Nope.
This one's 14.
This one's 5.
This one's 10.
So it's not a very long book at all.
His name is Phil McRae.
My favorite monster is the vampire from Sesame Street.
Some people think he doesn't count.
But I assure you he does.
This just sounds like dying at Monster Girls.
Monster Girls should be monstrous.
I...
But it's so strange that there are people that are like so into monster men.
I never knew it was a thing.
For like, normies and all.
Also on the cover of this book, it says...
Of the Love Laugh Lich.
It says...
These sex magic rituals aren't OSHA compliant.
And so I felt like I had to read it.
I was like, this is...
Um...
Yeah...
Thank you for the 10 gifted swamp!
Thank you so much.
But uh...
If you wanna see the cover of it, you can go to my Twitter.
I posted a screenshot.
Um...
But basically...
This guy is like...
The boss.
The way the narrator...
She does his voice is so...
I thought I was about to rip my hair out.
The men should be monstrous too.
Oh yeah, no.
These are monster men.
And...
When you said silly, I didn't expect this.
This is silly, no?
And so...
Um...
She works at the office.
And he needs a...
Uh...
Something for his spell.
But what he needs is a shiver?
I don't...
Really understand.
I don't understand it.
I guess...
Just put her in a cold room.
I don't really know.
What do you...
What...
What it...
Yeah, like...
Like a shiver.
Like a...
Of...
Osha approved...
S...
No!
And so, I guess that starts their little romance.
But he's kind of a jerk.
He's actually kind of really bad.
Like, just...
Just not nice to her.
And, um, he is shown on the cover as a skeleton man.
But actually, underneath his billowing cloak, which she loves to describe.
Oh, she's like, oh, it's a billowing cloak.
It's so shadowy.
It's... she loves describing it.
And, um, underneath, he's actually, um, a furry.
He's actually a furry with... three peepees stacked on top of each other.
So, um, I'll pick up where I last left off before I fell asleep.
Last night, and, uh...
Lich should not have any flesh.
But, I'm just... I don't know.
Thank you, DreadDot.
Thank you.
Three peepees and a trench coat.
What's the third one for?
I don't want to say on stream.
You know?
But...
They can't be side by side with the way they describe...
With the way she...
What?
How she said...
That was happening.
Here's some money for when this gets...
It won't get demonetized.
I said peepee.
So...
No, I think they're, like, one on top of each other.
Like...
I think...
Anyway, um...
Yes...
Welcome, everybody.
No, I'm not a human.
I'm a...
You can go back...
I'm a war!
I'm a...
Franklin!
I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a fish... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... Wow.
Wow, there's so many... so many species.
Isn't the... Isn't the world just so fascinating?
Isn't it just so fascinating?
What if it did spell Minto at one point?
Wouldn't that be crazy?
I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I'm a... I wish I had three peepees.
Honestly, I'm jelly.
I don't think... I think it would be way more... trouble than it's worth.
You are John Cena!
Um... Yeah.
I'm a crib!
I'm a... Weirdo...
But yeah.
Um... Some people were wondering if this... If the full game is out or not.
Uh... It's not.
But I still wanted to play it.
Um... I was just kind of like in the mood for...
I was in the mood for like a papers please type game.
You know what I mean?
So...
What is this emoji anchor?
What is that?
Thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
So I guess this is like a papers please, but a little spooky.
Let's start it.
Not really papers please.
No, it's not.
Oh, never mind.
I'm just kidding.
I lied.
This is my tiny house.
It's very quaint.
We've got one hallway.
Maybe?
What's in here?
Everything is so green.
Oh, this is my bedroom.
Okay, very nice.
This is... nothing.
I blocked myself out.
So someone's at the door.
Who could it be?
Can I peep?
People from the cities have already started coming to the neighbors.
People have changed.
A lot.
Does PP stand for pickle peanut?
That doesn't sound very good.
Oh my gosh, I once got... I remember I once got pickle flavored cashews at the airport.
I was like, these might be fine.
I like cashews.
I like pickles.
It was so... much pickle.
Taste.
Oh my gosh.
There's nothing to be scared, right?
Yeah.
I'm not an elf.
I'm just a ghost.
Yeah, it was so much dew.
It was so much pickle.
I was like...
If they come to your place, you let them in.
Oh, just be careful, okay?
Oh, I've heard of people being killed by other people.
Now I hear these stories more and more often.
Who are you?
Or do you want in?
An acquaintance said that creatures that look like humans are coming.
In a few days, they will tell me what signs can be used to distinguish them from humans.
Humans!
You can't stay alone.
Something very evil will come and...
Who knows what's next?
Are they skinwalkers?
Creepy.
Uh, what's going on out there?
It's safe to look out the windows at night.
And I even recommend it.
That way, you at least realize what surrounds your house.
It's hard to look out during the day.
It gets very hot.
The light hurts my eyes.
Uh, is it better not to leave the house now?
What do we do now?
That's why I brush my teeth with pickle-flavored toothpaste.
I'm immune to any pickly surprises.
People must love talking to you.
Um, what?
What?
Uh, is it...
Uh, what do I do?
Let's summarize.
There's gonna be people coming in at night.
You decide who to let in, who not.
It's hard to decide visually.
We'll be told later by the authorities what to do.
Look at the windows.
Don't know...
You don't know what's going on.
And keep your head down.
It's dangerous everywhere now.
I'll sleep in your cabinet.
Tonight.
And tomorrow you can do it yourself.
Well, I have a bed.
I don't...
I don't think I need to sleep in a cabinet.
My little...
He's my little possum pal.
Come and see me in the afternoon and we'll talk.
Okay.
Well, it's nighttime now.
No one else will come tonight.
Okay.
Wait, so I can look outside?
No, I cannot.
What cabinet are you in, mister?
The game with the peep-o-roop.
Peep-o-peep-o.
I can only sleep.
Hank Shuo.
Wow.
Creepers, creepers.
Where'd you get them peepers?
Good morning, dear viewer.
Ah, good morning, Meantau.
Good morning, Meantau.
It's the morning weather forecast.
The sun keeps shining and the summer heat persists in our town.
The duration of this heat has already broken a Guinness record.
And it seems that the good weather isn't going anywhere.
Don't you have to, like, pay for Guinness records?
So what?
The weather's rich, huh?
Huh?
The weather's like, hey, buddy.
Slips them a little...
A little...
A little ten.
Not always.
Oh, I see.
Can we trust this guy?
I don't know.
Can we trust anybody?
Seems that the good weather isn't going anywhere.
Scientists are closely monitoring solar activity and predict its intensification.
But they assure us there's no need to worry.
I think that's gonna change.
So grab your sunglasses, take your best swimsuits, and don't forget your hats.
And most importantly, make sure you don't get sunstroke.
Lately, there's been more weird behavior in the town.
And experts think it's because of too much sun.
We were right!
Too much sun!
Mm-hmm.
Don't go outside.
Good morning, Minto.
Oh.
Oh, I have energy up here.
And this will waste one.
We gotta go talk to our cabinet.
Dweller.
Are you in here?
So this is our living room.
Is there some...
You just sit on the couch and don't do anything?
What's in here?
Oh, god!
Oh, wow!
This is not the cabinet.
Wow!
Kitchen?
We got ourselves a kitchen.
This is zero.
Wait.
My head's kind of blocking it.
But it says energy equals zero.
So maybe...
Oh, maybe that will waste all of my energy.
Pantry?
Oh, it skips the day!
I see, I see, I see.
And then our bathroom.
Look at that!
We got everything that we need here.
In our quaint little home.
Can I see outside?
I think the hallway would scare me at night.
But let's talk to...
To Joe Cabinet.
Did you see the newscast?
It's a nightmare!
Okay, in this heat, every dialogue is going to waste your energy.
So think hard about who you want to talk to.
And one more thing.
Checking people for signs of guests should be in the dialogue, too.
There's an actual solar storm passing next week.
How?
So be careful how you spend your energies.
If you decide you've talked to everyone and don't want to sleep, have a beer.
Go to the kitchen, have a cold one from the fridge.
It'll use up all your energy and you'll want to sleep right away.
So I'm just supposed to sit around and survive?
Yeah, beer o'clock, baby.
That's kind of weird, don't you think?
Let me preface this with a word, just in case.
During the day, you can talk to your house guests about all sorts of things.
Human things.
In dialogue with them, you can check for signs of fake people.
Toasty.
Next, you can decide what to do with those who are not human, in your opinion.
If you don't...
Sorry.
If you don't want to communicate with anyone else, but still have the strength, drink beer in the kitchen.
There's one in the fridge I brought you to chill.
It'll make you so sleepy.
I'm already sleepy.
And wait for help.
If they call an evacuation, stay close to my family.
Now have a beer and get some rest.
You look tired.
By the way, I heard that at night.
Someone walks around asking if you're home alone.
If you open the door, don't say that you're alone.
Well, you're in my cabinet, so I'm not going to say that.
Oh wait, my bad.
Oh no!
I used one!
I'm just supposed to sit around?
Okay.
Okay, I wasted one.
But it's fine, because I think we didn't have anything else to do.
Oops.
I can't look outside yet.
I think I have to just, uh...
Wait, let's go watch the TV.
This guy is speaking my language.
You watch graceful ballerinas gliding across the stage.
Performance beautiful...
Oh, performing beautiful pirouettes.
Wow.
My favorite channel.
Classical dance brings back warm childhood memories and makes you think of beautiful things.
At least most of these rooms don't have windows.
You know, so...
Nothing's going to crawl in, maybe.
Do you think that was like a ballerina blotch test?
Like...
Like, what do you see from the lines?
Oh my god.
A visitor?
You see several teenagers spending time in a field outside the window.
Wow.
They're sitting around chatting excitedly, not paying attention to you.
Kids, it's...
It's laid out!
Where are your parents?
Get home.
I guess they can't play in the...
Well...
The weather said...
The newsman said it wasn't so bad yet.
In the distance is the neighbor's house.
The neighbor is visiting, you know.
The lights are on in the windows and the family seems to be waiting for him to leave...
Uh...
To leave you back home for dinner.
Yeah.
Is this, like, this guy?
Oh.
I can't open the door, okay.
It's dead quiet outside.
Spooky!
Nobody's there.
Even the alcoholics, for some unknown reason, decided not to show up on the street.
Are they afraid of someone?
Who's here?
Vanilla, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Vanilla.
Happy birthday!
Let's see who our first person is.
Oh, is my dad here?
Can you call him?
It wasn't scary during the day, but now it is.
A lot of people went out at night.
Uh... Tell me something about your dad.
I can tell you a lot.
Before he goes out, he likes to have a little beer.
He leaves me lunch, dinner, and... Oh.
I almost read beer!
Today I tried the beer!
Uh-oh.
You need some parental supervision.
Today I tried the beer he drinks.
Ugh.
It was awful.
I drink that when there's juice.
She's so... she's so real.
She's so real for that.
Oh, please don't tell him.
Um...
Did you get here safely?
You know...
It's like everything is turned upside down.
People now stay indoors or sleep during the day.
At night, they go out and do things.
I'm still not used to being afraid of the dark.
But it seems like there's nothing to fear.
Wait.
What do you mean you're not used to being afraid of the dark?
Would you ever be you?
Or is there?
Uh...
I'm calling Dad for you.
Good luck.
Have a good time!
We just send her on her way.
I think the translation of this game was a little rough.
Ah...
I see, I see, I see.
Um...
How do we know...
I mean, he did like beer.
But that's like...
It's also my B-Day.
I actually completely forgot until my sister texted me.
Happy birthday, Kamori!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Kamori Asani.
Oh, she's probably fine.
I'll call for your dad.
Thanks.
Good luck to you, too.
We go now.
I'm scared to be outside alone at night.
We're going to play a game.
He made some kind of game where you have to roll a dice.
And then walk on objects.
I mean, like a chair or a couch.
And then you have to build a road.
Anyway, I'll show you later.
What?
Oh!
Goodbye!
Bye!
Oh!
I'll miss you, Possum!
I don't know.
Why would we even...
I don't think I know his name, though.
I just call him Possum.
So...
I don't...
I don't know...
Uh...
What...
If I had asked her what his name was, I don't think I would have gotten anything.
It's the creep family.
Do you think she gets it more from him or her mom?
I was hiding in the pub, but...
I was kicked out.
Why?
Not everyone can handle my temper.
It's not my birthday.
Well, happy un-birthday.
Not birthday.
Long man, look at those arms!
Wait, why are you telling me this?
You went inside my house, but you have a temper?
But look at them cheekbones!
Scarlett Johansson.
But I don't mean to offend anyone.
Don't get me wrong.
It's just...
Sometimes it gets sickening.
You know how it is.
What do you think?
Will you let me in?
Uh...
You're not a visitor, aren't you?
Are you sure there won't be any trouble with you?
Conjoined for the stream you did on my birthday.
Hope you feel better.
Annick!
Happy Evelyn birthday!
This guy's kind of long, but we have nothing to go off of.
He looks like the caveman from I Have No Mouth and I Must Scream.
Oh, let me sing happy...
Happy birthday to you!
Happy Happy Birthday to you!
Happy Birthday dear Annick!
Happy Birthday to you!
Sorry!
My brain is slow!
It's having a bad day!
I hope it's better!
I hope it gets better!
I might have to stop doing birthday songs again, you guys.
I'm not gonna lie because...
My throat has been so bad again recently.
I don't know why!
Ugh!
Ever since last week!
So I might have to stop doing birthday songs for the next...
Maybe even the next month or so.
Because I have so many things that I have to get done.
I have so many things I need to record!
So...
Yeah...
I was screaming during Doki's stream.
Yeah, but my throat hurted...
Hurted?
But...
I...
It was even before then though, so...
I feel like I'm falling apart recently.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Oh, let's just...
You're not a visitor!
You think I'm one of those monsters?
No, I'm no visitor.
But asking everyone to keep their face about it is just crazy.
Thank you for that day gift!
Thank you!
Anyway, it will be like that from now on.
Oh...
Why did they kick you out of your last shelter?
I love that you take a few moments to sing happy birthday.
Thank you!
I try!
Oh...
No answer?
I was thinking of...
Thinking to tell you something offensive, but I changed my mind.
I told you, people just felt uncomfortable with me there.
There were all sorts of weirdos.
When I think about it, maybe it was for the best that they kicked me out.
Those would've...
Those would've eaten me alive and not even noticed.
Wow, he is...
Nobody else is the weirdo...
Or wait...
Wait...
I'm not the weirdo!
Everyone else is weird!
I kind of understand.
Come on in!
Oh!
He's got a nice little smile!
Thanks.
Trusting people nowadays is worth no more than a coin.
Maybe that's why I appreciate your trust.
Maybe.
Alright, I can't promise anything.
Okay.
Anyone else?
Oh!
Gosh!
Busy house!
Where is he?
Pre-record...
No, I feel like that's so disingenuous.
Ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
Oh!
Sorry for disturbing you so late.
It's just too hot during the day.
The TV said it's better not to go out in the sun.
Is there any corner for me?
Uh...
Who are you?
I used to live closer to the town.
The asphalt heats up pretty intensely out there.
Ha ha!
I used to work as a cashier.
Not anymore though.
I got fired.
Just didn't have any luck with work.
You got fired from being a cashier?
Uh...
What do you think will happen in the future?
Such a...
Wow.
Such a deep question.
I don't know.
Will I survive?
Who will help me?
How long will I have to search for help?
Wait, so then all the stores, are they just open at night now?
I won't request a birthday song next week.
Of course you can still say it's your birthday and I'll wish you a happy birthday.
I don't know what will happen next.
I can't even guess.
Aren't you scared by this?
I am.
Very much so.
You need to go to a doctor.
What if this...
I...
Okay, I'm not convinced that this isn't just two people in a t-shirt.
I'm not convinced that there's not someone hiding underneath that t-shirt.
You were...
You were a cashier?
No.
You would have...
You would have been more believable if you said you were a gamer.
I had this haircut when I was 13.
Who do you think works as cashiers, Minto?
So...
What?
No.
She smuggled the cash register in her shirt.
She got a little scoliosis.
She's scared, but...
Lord Farquaad looking rough.
Ah, Greg.
Welcome to Bubbleship.
Thank you.
Okay, we'll be nice for now.
Oh, thank you, really.
Oh, God, I'll live one more day.
Oh.
No one else will come tonight.
Okay, I guess, uh...
I guess nothing else happens in...
In the windows.
Oh, the children are still there.
Why do people need to stay at my house?
Don't they have their own houses?
Like those children, are they gonna ask to stay at my house?
Oh.
We interrupt our morning show for an urgent message.
Tell my brother Mason happy birthday.
Oh!
Happy birthday, Mason!
Come on!
Yeah.
Today at 628 AM, there was a powerful solar energy eruption.
This flare was larger than scientists predicted.
The air temperature has reached a critical level.
Authorities have declared a state of emergency.
Oh, Nyaru!
Thank you so much for the rain!
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome, Raiders.
We urge all citizens to avoid going outside during daylight hours.
Marilyn!
Nookie!
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Thank you!
Now on to the news.
Aliens?
People emerging from underground?
No, this isn't a sci-fi story or a tabloid headline!
And Draco, thank you so much for the gifted.
Eyewitnesses report contact with visitors around the city.
One witness encountered a middle-aged man who had perfectly white teeth.
It turns out he was one of these visitors.
Pay attention to their teeth.
Oh, gosh.
Sorry if you had a good dental routine.
Hello?
Um, I think there's more to be concerned about here, though, no?
This person had a whole...
Whole surgery done.
Brow lift.
Rhinoplasty.
Chin...
Injection?
What is this?
Similar incidents with visitors sporting perfect teeth have been observed.
They're jealous of how big his chin is.
He's his...
Mewing king.
Should not view...
Should have not viewed that hard.
Yeah.
So if you want to identify them, check their teeth.
Please stay alert and calm.
Let's move on to other news.
Alright.
Guess we gotta go check her.
Long man's teeth.
Hello, long man.
Yeah, did you want something?
Uh...
What do you know about the cataclysm?
I need to check on you.
How do you recognize a visitor?
Uh...
What is the cataclysm?
The sun is exploding.
There's a real hell on Earth.
Without metaphors and purgatory.
No one trusts anyone.
People are literally being burned alive during the day.
And people are ready to sell their own mothers for shelter.
I want to believe in people.
But it's so hard to do so.
Can I check your teeth?
Teeth.
Do you want to see my teeth?
Well, look at them.
They still have the taste of unhappiness and smoke on them.
Oh!
Those aren't perfect.
Those...
Are not perfect.
The...
The visitors all have veneers.
Thank you.
I'm glad my streams make you happy.
The nonogram stream got me addicted to the tower.
I think he's good.
Yellowish, huh?
Well, don't F with me with your tests.
I'm not a visitor.
Okay...
Lady?
Where you at, lady?
I like how I have, like, these...
Like...
Is that supposed to be Marilyn Monroe over there?
This is why I stay out of San Francisco.
What's in San Francisco?
Wow!
We have, like, a water...
A water heater, even.
Wow.
Oh!
Uh-huh.
Hopefully this will all be over soon.
I need to check on you.
What do you want to check?
Your teeth.
Huh?
Are you going to make decisions based on teeth?
Uh-oh.
I've had my teeth fixed recently.
Although, to be honest...
I can't remember when I've been to the dentist.
Have I even been to one?
Wait, how'd you get your teeth fixed, then?
What?
Oh, golly.
We shouldn't have let this lady in.
Uh...
What?
Where did you get your teeth fixed?
How did you get them fixed if you went...
Uh...
Some...
Back alley...
Sussy...
Operation.
How do you know that you got your fixed...
Or your teeth fixed recently, but you don't know?
Uh...
God, I can't even remember what I ate yesterday because of fear.
Oh!
Everyone in Hollywood would be like...
So in trouble if this were...
If this were an actual indicator.
Everybody with their stinking veneers...
They would all be like...
Oh!
Let me just pop my tooth out!
Let all get those lit.
Um...
Does that...
Do I fit the description?
Oh!
That can't be...
That can't be a visitor, yes?
Uh...
I'll hear...
I'll hear her out!
Blammo!
Take her out!
What if she eats me?
Um...
I don't even know where I'm pointing this thing.
Hahaha!
Shoot!
I feel like I'm being peer pressured into murder.
Hahaha!
Is this hazing?
Is this a hazing ritual?
Um...
She doesn't look human?
She looks like the girl from...
Uh...
What's that movie?
The Fifth Element.
You never trusted that shoulder.
I still think there's...
You know what?
No!
Please!
Don't!
Maybe we should've heard her out.
Uh...
Ooh!
I'm just gonna clean that up.
We have no visitors in our...
They don't come through the tubs, do they?
I guess we'll watch TV since I have one more, uh...
One more energy.
Every time chat is going to tell you to do the most horrific thing possible.
I'm not listening to chat.
I'm listening to my own instincts.
Heat outside?
No problem.
When you have...
Energica in hand...
This refreshing energy drink quenches thirst even in the hottest heat.
A unique blend of lime and...
Gives extraordinary energy!
You put the lime in the mint...
And shake it all...
Meets back on the many boys!
Energica!
Look for it in nearby stores!
Dynamic energy drink advertisement.
Subtly satisfying your thirst.
What do you mean, subtly?
Okay.
Time for sleepy.
Oh wait, let's look out the window.
Outside the window stands a neighbor and his daughter.
Oh, that's the guy from before, no?
They play happily together, forgetting the horror that is happening.
Just for a moment.
Watching this makes you remember your childhood.
It gives you a warm feeling of nostalgia.
Aww...
The bodies of teenagers are...
On the ground!
They're... napping?
Someone killed them!
They're not napping?
Lime and mint, mojito?
It seems to be recent, because the blood hasn't dried yet.
The picture gives you goosebumps and makes you feel a little uneasy.
Oh...
This is...
Oh gosh, this reminds...
This looks like a picture...
Like a scene from that...
Storybook.
The scariest stories...
Tell in the...
The dark...
Sorry, my brain isn't...
Blub...
He looks friendly...
I wish he'd put on a shirt!
On the path stands a man as pale as death itself.
There are strange folds in his skin.
This skin seems to be too big...
Wait, they really are skinwalkers!
Seems to be too big for him!
You can't see his eyes from here, but you can feel him...
Drilling you with his gaze.
He's just gotta fill in...
He's just...
He's a growing boy!
You feel fear and pray to God that the creepy visitor will avoid the house.
Is that one of the alcoholics they were talking about?
I expected more like...
Matarakan...
Image, but...
Oh, hello!
Let me tell you right away...
I'm not afraid of the heat...
But I'm still looking for a quiet place.
Can I find peace at your place?
Who are you?
How long have you been looking for a peaceful place?
Hmmm...
Peace!
Welcome to membership!
I like how she didn't even...
None of these people even say hello!
She's like...
I'm not afraid of the heat!
How long have you been looking for a peaceful place?
There's never been any peace for me.
So yeah...
A long time.
Matara is too grotesque to put in a game!
So true!
Take off your jacket!
I think I'm a freak!
Are you okay with the heat?
Wait, why is she wearing a jacket anyway?
Isn't it supposed to be mega hot?
Kevin!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Alright, take off your jacket!
No.
It's okay if you won't let me in.
I'll just keep moving.
I'm not gonna beg or bother you.
Okay, come on in!
The ceiling is a little low here.
Never mind, we're gonna kill her.
Don't complain about my...
My cute little cottage house!
It's cottagecore!
Where are you?
Is that guy still there?
Wait...
I thought he was closer for a second.
He looks spooky.
Oh, whoa!
Jack Black!
How fortunate we are!
We've witnessed first-hand the consequences of human passions!
I am Steve.
The earth will be cleansed, the sun will do its work.
And we will go to a new clean world!
Yeah!
Oh, wow.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry for that.
I'm really sorry about that.
That's the effing good news!
What?
What are you doing, human?
Listen to me.
I'll give you a brief rundown.
The sun burns and burns us for a reason.
It bakes seeds out of us.
Okay, I definitely think this guy is human.
We've all done all sorts of things, and now the sun is angry!
Give his head to us!
What does that mean?
Yeah, I think that he's part of some sort of sun cult.
He's weird but harmless.
La-la-la-la-la-la-la-la!
You-you-you-you-you-you-been!
The sun's so hot, it feels like lava outside!
Hey, Ben Robez!
Thank you so much, Mr. Thank you, Mr. Thank you!
Mr.
Thank you!
That's a good thing.
All our sins will be over.
We'll live our lives properly.
Uh... What's... Wait.
You mean we all have to die?
Nah.
Sins will fade away.
The sun may die, but we will live.
There will be no more deaths.
No more stealing.
No more greedy bastards who can't sell me what I want for a fair price.
Can you imagine such a thing?
Do you realize what this is all about?
Wait, we're gonna let him in after that?
Um... Hmm...
Jack, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I think he's... I think he's human.
I can tell you a lot more about all this.
Do you have any beer?
I forgot to ask.
So now we have...
Three people.
We have room for...
Two more, I guess, I hope.
As long as they don't mind the body in the pantry, you know.
We just invited Steve.
Oh!
Too bad we are the witnesses.
Maybe we are... participants too.
Uh, what do you need anything?
No thanks.
Everything I need is already there.
And what I don't have, you can't help me with.
Well, you read my fortune.
Choose where I should open the book and read a lot.
Uh...
What are you talking about?
You're weird.
If you don't need anything, then leave?
What are you talking about?
That's how you look at it.
What do my words mean to you?
Will you read my fortune from a book?
Howie Mandel?
Deal or no deal?
Human or not human?
Uh...
Open at the beginning, top paragraph.
Open near the middle, last paragraph.
Let's do the middle.
The dead will come and tell.
And he will not be believed.
What does that mean?
I need to think now.
Maybe I'll see you later.
Oh!
I didn't have to let him in.
He left himself.
Why are you bothering me?
Why are you...
Why did you come to my house then?
Oh, no one else will come tonight.
Okay.
We are a house full of completely only humans.
I hope I don't die in the middle of the night.
Oh!
Good morning, Minto.
This is the morning news.
Solar activity remains abnormal.
And experts predict that it will continue to intensify.
There are continuing reports from eyewitnesses about encounters with visitors.
You know...
What this makes me think of is...
What makes...
What...
This makes me think of is...
Basically, what's going on...
On, like, planet Earth...
When Outer Wilds is happening.
Robot Kitchen, happy birthday!
Unfortunately...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I can't do a birthday song.
But I will wish you a happy, happy, happy birthday!
Yeah.
True.
In response to the situation, authorities urgently ramped up FEMA operations.
Actually, I am gonna grab a cough drop, too.
Let me grab one.
I accidentally grabbed two.
That's fine.
FEMA is an acronym for the Federal Emergency Management Agency.
FEMA...
Stuff?
Members?
What?
Staff?
FEMA staff members wear yellow hazmat suit.
The FEMA special committee started functioning recently.
But they have discovered a new indicator of visitors.
Oh.
The Stuff members.
Oh my gosh, Briar.
I was literally thinking that.
Stuff member has died.
I was literally thinking...
I was about to say it and then I saw your comment.
That's crazy.
Doing stuff.
Stuff.
Of course you were.
The FEMA special committee experts believe that besides teeth, visitors can be identified by dirt under their nails.
Oh, because they crawl out from the...
Yeah, as reported by FEMA, this was discovered during an inspection of one of the houses.
FEMA...
NUTS!
...
Employees encountered a woman who had worked as a nurse.
For some unknown reason, she had dirt under her nails.
God forbid a lady has hobbies.
Given that visitors emerged from the ground, the woman was taken in for testing.
Her dangerous status was confirmed.
If you notice anyone resembling a visitor...
Promptly contact FEMA.
Members are called the hotline at 0451.
Please stay alert and calm and avoid leaving your home during daylight hours.
Now let's move on to the...
What other news could there be?
What else could be going on?
Tall man!
Oh!
Yeah, did you want something?
I don't like how close they're sitting next to them.
Uh, I need to check on you.
Long-haired bitch with a dream!
Thank you, Rodrigo!
I'm embarrassed about the article, but thank you!
How many people did we let in?
Let in her?
Let in Jack Black?
So we should be able...
I wanna ask...
This guy seems pretty reasonable, you know?
How many victims are there?
Hundreds?
Oh, thousands?
Hundreds of thousands?
Millions?
Honestly, I have absolutely no idea.
No one will tell you.
So you don't piss your pants in fear.
No matter what number you come up with...
Triple it.
One...
Billion...
Quadrillion...
Million...
Ultra...
Zillion...
Bangdillion?
Triple that!
It's probably closer to the actual number of victims.
I wish there was some warmth!
This lady is freaking...
I don't think we should've let her in.
Oh, I need to check on you.
What do you wanna check?
Let me see them hands.
Nails?
I'll show you.
Hmm...
Looks like I chipped them...
All or something.
Chipped them all?
Let's take a look anyway.
Oh!
Chipped them, you say?
Do you think my fingernails fit the sign of a visitor?
Oh!
Got it.
There's like nothing...
Nothing behind those eyes.
Except...
The craving of human flesh.
Probably.
Umm...
Fire in the hole!
You know what?
Oh!
I didn't even get to re...
Mister, you can move!
You can change rooms!
Do you think we can fix her with a manicure?
Get her some...
Some press-ons.
And she'll be looking dandy.
I need to check on your nails.
Where did they even come from?
Dirt under the fingernails?
Is that supposed to be a sign?
They can just wash their hands!
That's all it takes!
Well, clearly they...
Don't!
How do you know she was a human?
So what, every gardener is a visitor now?
That's ridiculous!
Look at the nails!
My man's clean!
What do you mean?
A pat his head.
Well, am I a visitor?
Of course not.
I think we did the right thing!
Why would all of her nails be off?
Why is she cold, but literally the sun is melting the planet?
I think we...
I think...
I think we're fine!
I don't think we're fine!
Hello?
Are you hungry?
What was that?
Hello?
Oh no, wait!
Who are the visitors?
Oh gosh, I just wasted up the energy.
There's something humanity has never faced before.
They just slap a label on something unknown and hate it.
As if this has never happened before.
I don't think it has.
People are fundamentally flawed.
What can you do?
Okay, we're gonna...
Uh-oh!
She's a cat!
Big kitty!
Oh, look!
We cleaned her up!
Perfect!
Um...
Is he in the bathroom?
Oh, hello!
I listen to your words, human!
Speak!
I need to check on you.
Me...
When there's no minto...
Show me your...
Hands!
No taboo, my friend!
Watch my nails as long as you like!
I've trained myself to get useful sunlight with them!
And open beer caps!
Oh!
I look clean to me!
Okay...
Clean as a whistle, yeah.
Did you...
Uh...
Just wanna check it out?
I thought...
Ugh!
You're just an evil man!
What the...
I let you into my hole!
You're sitting on my washing machine!
But I'm evil?
You think this guy's still growling over here?
You guys, I can't check his teeth because I don't have any more energies!
I accidentally wasted one.
It's okay.
We probably...
Won't die.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to check the window over here.
Oh!
Gosh!
I thought they were zombies!
They're a small group of FEMA staff standing outside a neighbor's house.
Wait, our neighbor!
I wonder what they're talking about.
Maybe they're taking soil samples.
Or they are looking for a place to set up base.
Makes you feel a little better to think that someone is trying to make sense of this nightmare.
Yeah, I'm right outside our house.
We are...
We are so good to go.
We are so safe.
Corporate zombies!
Oh, look!
The bodies of teenagers burned to death on the ground!
The sun burned them!
They seem to have been lying here all day.
Two emergency workers are standing next to the bodies and writing something down.
It's good that there are those who can remove the bodies.
It's scary to imagine what kind of contagion could appear.
The rotting bodies are not removed from the streets.
I mean, if they're burnt to a crisp...
It doesn't seem like they'll have any contagion.
It sounds like jerky to me!
Nice!
There's a group of armed soldiers outside the window.
Oh my gosh!
They're all...
Grouping around our house!
We're gonna be so safe.
Chicken jerky!
Apparently there are small units sent here from the city to provide security for the EC.
Human jerky finds!
Thank you!
Whenever I work at the office, I have your VODs livestreams on my second monitor.
Now if any of my colleagues ask about you, I can show them your business insider interview!
I'm so...
I'm so legit now, no?
Thank you!
You can only hear bits and pieces of phrases from about a pale man with a bare torso!
No, it was a pale torso.
He was shirtless.
He wasn't a bear at all.
In fact, I don't think he had hair.
Maybe they want to track down that creepy stranger.
You feel relieved that there are people ready to deal with a dangerous guest on the streets.
Who is it?
Oh!
Is that our guy?
No way.
It's the man from the thumbnail!
Um...
Who are you?
How's it going there?
Is everything...
Okay?
Well...
He couldn't even grow nipples.
He's so wide, but his arms are so skinny.
He's got them perfect teeth!
Um...
What do you want?
Listen...
Are you alone in the house?
Just curious.
You're just reading someone's fortune.
Promising salvation to some.
Driving some away.
Uh...
What if I say I'm alone?
They said not to tell the creepy...
Creepy guy that you're alone.
And what if he knows I'm lying?
One Piece character.
I wouldn't.
Intrusive thoughts, Pinky.
Don't do it.
I'm just so curious!
He'll kill me!
Really?
I don't want to start the game over, though.
Is the game over, actually?
Oh, I don't want to start the game over.
I have other people taking shelter here.
I gotta go...
Bye, nun!
Have a good day.
You're lucky tonight.
Yeah, I am getting lucky tonight.
Uh...
I can hear someone whispering in your rooms.
But who knows what will happen tomorrow.
Okay.
Hey, you guys!
He was right there!
You guys!
He was at my door!
You guys are blind!
Did it...
Did anyone knock?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Can I rest at your place?
Your...
Your friend is drunk?
Wait...
I've gotten some bruises.
What?
Melty!
Happy birthday!
I think it's your birthday?
I'm kinda confused.
Have...
Don't hurt yourself.
Can I rest at your place?
Uh...
Where did you come from?
I don't remember anymore.
I don't care about it.
I'm very tired.
If I don't get some rest, I'll just collapse from exhaustion.
Uh...
Does your friend need help?
Um...
Not anymore.
When he needed it, no one helped.
Oh!
He's not asleep?
Oh...
Now he's dead.
He might be alive if...
Anyone gave a hoot.
I...
That's like two mouths to fit.
Um...
I don't want a stinky corpse in my home.
What if he...
What if he turns into a zombie?
And then he starts feasting on all of our brains.
That's the second mouth, you guys.
We don't know anything...
What if that's the next symptom that happens?
Zombification.
I have a gun.
What if he eats me in my sleeve?
You gotta trust people more?
There...
Hmm...
What if one of the...
One of the cool zombies that runs really fast?
And I can't even shoot him in time.
Hmm...
Kinda sus.
I don't mind still killing people, but... What if it's a friendly zombie?
That's like so rare.
I don't want a stinky body.
Where are we gonna put the body?
I don't want a stinky body in my home.
It's decomposing, you guys.
We're gonna get maggots and worms.
and flies and everything.
In the closet?
Next to our food?
Where'd you put the last two?
I made them into jerky.
Chicken jerky.
Made of human.
Why do you guys want me to let them in?
already two corpses.
No, they're gone.
This nice person needs a place to stay.
Well, as long as she leaves in the morning.
Well, I guess in the morning evening.
Okay, come on in.
I don't think I'll stay long.
I just need a break.
Oh, Muggas?
Who's?
You see what's going on?
Freaking heck.
How's it going down here?
Uh, what's going on?
New opportunities?
Can't ya freaking see?
Everybody's whining, running around, fussing...
Well, you can't just do things from the heart.
That's all.
We should be happy, and sure.
Is that perfect teeth or no?
I can't tell.
Omogus.
What are you offering?
Why did you come to me?
Oh, he is missing a tooth, yeah.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
What are you offering?
Survive.
What else is there?
ViviCore, thanks for the gifted.
Kister, welcome to membership, thank you.
And Elpen's welcome back, thank you.
We gotta make plans while we can.
To hell with the sun.
Keep moving, you know?
Let's go, shall we?
Um... I guess he seems fine too.
Funny Among Us shirt.
I've literally let everyone in at this point then.
I can't turn them away!
I can't... I have to let everybody in!
I can't...
I am not letting everybody in!
He's... when... when... when... when... when... when the shirt is... gosh...
Everybody but the box art guy.
Wait, who was that?
Oh, he wouldn't let me.
Wait, the box art.
Like, the thumbnail?
He's sus.
What if it's a warning?
What if he's actually sus?
The shirt is bait?
What if the Among Us is a red herring?
What if it's a red herring?
What if it's... What if it's a hint?
I don't know.
Alright.
Oh, oh, oh.
Now we're talking.
Finally.
Someone with some sense.
Bitch!
What the hell?
You guys, I don't want him in here!
He's rude!
I dislike his fouling.
Me too!
He has teeth.
He curses too much.
Doctor...
It's so quiet at night.
Hi.
Can I come in?
Have you been watching the house?
Are you looking for something?
Why would you think that?
No.
I'm actually looking for something.
But the same thing everyone else is.
Safety.
And a way to...
Kill.
Boredom.
Tch.
Hahahaha.
And you guys are so quiet at night.
I honestly didn't think anyone slept here.
So I thought I'd check if...
It's okay to come in.
But it was locked.
What?
You...
You just tried to let yourself in?!
I was about to knock before I tried breaking the door down.
I mean you did knock.
That's how I knew you were here.
Um...
Who are you?
I'm a traveling doctor now.
Hospitals are chaotic.
I highly advise against going there.
This guy looks like he has no teeth.
So I don't think he's...
I've operated on people.
I'm a surgeon.
There wasn't enough funding at our hospital.
So I've done a lot of other jobs that aren't typically mine.
Now I just go around helping whoever I can.
Okay.
Oh, he's a nice old man.
I hope I can help someone.
Even though he tried to break into my home.
I think he's fine.
Oh, wow that was fast.
No, I definitely heard a knock.
Oh, no one else will come tonight.
Oh, that was creepy.
Wait, are we sure?
G-g-g-g-ghost?
I might die in the middle of the night.
Is this guy still hungry?
No?
But we're safe.
We have the whole...
We have the whole crew outside.
I think we're fine.
The window?
Yeah, we can check the window.
You guys heard that though too, right?
A knock at the window.
Oh gosh, sorry.
That scared me.
Uh...
Yeah, how are you doing?
No?
Hmm...
Okay, I'm asleep.
Someone's ding-dong ditching.
Good morning, Minto.
This is the morning news.
The valiant FEMA staff members have organized quarantine zones.
Anyone showing signs of visitors is directed there.
Some people express concern that the identity of visitors remains unknown.
Sounds like they're zombies, no?
If they're coming from the ground.
However, FEMA assures that they are merely ill individuals in need of assistance.
Additionally, FEMA has identified a new indicator of visitors.
Intensely irritated blood red eyes.
Lizard people.
Mole people.
They seem more like body snatchers.
Yeah!
I think so.
This information was discovered through experiments with detained guests.
According to FEMA experts, the irritation is caused by exposure to bright sunlight.
So anybody outside?
Mint people.
Crab people.
Please stay alert and calm and avoid leaving your home during daylight hours.
We'll move on to other news.
Alright.
Good morning!
Oh!
You guys saw that, right?
I was kind of blocking it.
I'm so sorry.
But there was definitely someone in that chair.
It was there for a second.
A literal second.
Might be in a different room now.
Huh?
Who are you?
The doctor is in the closet?
Oh, it's Among Us guy.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
I told you, this looks so wrong.
You are.
I was so sorry.
I SdO aoster.
You are.
Guys!
There's something wrong in there.
Um...
My sister's share her birthday.
She's five years older than me, so did I steal her birthday or am I just fashionably belayed twin?
Probably your parents have really great timing.
Thank you for the super chat!
Oh gosh, I think this guy is fine, so I don't think we need to check him anymore.
But we have this guy here.
What's up, B?
This guy!
I don't know you like that!
Somebody is fighting demons in the bathroom.
Um...
I need to check on you.
What do you want to check?
Show me your eyes!
My eyes have been itchy these days.
Do you think it's from the sun or what?
Freak!
Oh!
It's just some kind of disease!
Disease?
What do you mean disease?
Hold on, hold on.
I want to check his nails too.
Listen, I just came up with a scheme.
Let's take money from others so we don't have to shoot them in the face.
Oh.
Imagine...
How much we'll make!
Bitch!
Stop calling me that!
Oh, his nails are fine.
I...
You know, I get dry eye.
I don't feel like you can just say that their eye is being irritated or...
You know...
Well, you don't think so?
I wash.
I just didn't have time to rinse my hands today.
Usually my nails are clean.
Bitch.
I hate this guy!
Hahaha!
Hold on.
We have other people we need to check, you guys.
I need to check on you.
What do you want to check?
Give me your...
If he is a doctor, he would have clean hands.
Guess I've operated on so many people with his hands.
I could tell you so many stories, but maybe another time.
Now please look.
Oh!
Yeah, that's grandpa's hands.
I try to keep these arms toned so I don't slack off.
Okay, who knows what tomorrow might bring.
Love the blood on his shirt.
He's a surgeon!
Let's check his teeth.
Because he hasn't smiled.
Thank you, my teeth are fine.
Ah, it's the visitor signs you're asking about.
Sure, look.
But he's a doctor!
He has the money!
Perfect, eh?
I had a friend of mine put them on for free.
And I operated on him a while ago.
I wonder how he is now.
We just get the gun out.
Um...
I think he's fine.
He's fine.
He's a doctor.
If you want, we can fix your teeth too.
Thank you so much for the braid!
For cheap, of course, and to help me out.
Once all this sun madness is over, that is.
Yeah.
Okay, so we have a monster in our bathroom.
Wait...
Oh my god, it's so loud!
Hello!
Which one of you?
Which one of you is it?
I can only check three more things, so...
I'm listening to you.
Uh...
Let's check his eyes.
Look into my dark eyes.
I absorb all the blessings of light with them, transforming energy from them.
I get all my strength from my eyes.
Oh.
Oh boy.
Oh no!
I think he needs to go to a doctor!
We have a doctor!
Yeah, he's fine, he just has liver damage.
Do you see the true power of the sun in my eyes?
If not, you're just blind.
Try looking at the sun for a longer time as I do.
Oh!
Where'd your zombie friend go?
I need to get some rest.
What do you want to check?
Do I go?
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you!
We can only check two things.
I'm gonna do...
I feel like since she's tired, the eyes might be...
I feel like hands and teeth would be better to check.
Because I feel like someone could get red eyes if they're tired, you know?
So let's do the teeth.
What?
Okay.
That's not perfect.
She's got a gap.
That's it?
Can I have some quiet time here alone?
Okay.
Then who's growling in here?
What?
I guess it doesn't bother her.
Check her again.
Her hands.
Hands.
Wait a second.
My hands are tired from carrying the one they refused to save.
Oh!
No, she's fine.
Must I even be asked to do this freaking thing?
If you want to shoot, just shoot.
I don't have the strength anymore.
This poor...
This prison's going through it.
I'm sorry.
No, I'm sorry.
I'm just really exhausted.
You know, we have like another room that has a couch that you could lay on.
You know?
Are we sure he's dead?
I don't know.
What is she soaking him in?
Other people need to shower and you got your dead body in there.
What is that?
Like, did you break formaldehyde too?
I don't understand.
Human soup.
Just like the mummy.
Oh my gosh.
You guys remember when they found that mummy?
And he was just a bunch of soup and everyone was just like, We're gonna eat the soup.
Was that pre-COVID?
That was a long time ago.
It was...
The coffin juice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
First time I'm hearing that...
Oh my gosh!
It was like a meme.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look it up.
If I look up coffin juice, I wonder.
Oh yeah, people want to drink the skeleton soup.
It was like a dark red liquid inside of a sarcophagus.
People were like...
I wanna...
I wanna slurp that up.
Where was this from?
Mysterious sarcophagus opened.
Maybe we shouldn't have opened that.
Egyptian archaeologists have unsealed and opened a mysterious granite sarcophagus discovered on a construction site in Alexandria.
Only to find the remains of three mummies in a pool of leaked...
Oh, it says sewage water.
No, I don't believe that.
That's not fun.
It's the mummy juice.
January 2019 is the article I found.
Mine...
I saw one that said 2018.
Uh...
This one is from July 2018.
I don't know, guys!
I don't know!
I hope nobody gets eaten!
I hope everything's fine!
Gamer Girl bath water.
Oh, yeah!
The neighbor's house which was recently painted white burned to the ground!
And is now completely black.
They burned their house down!
The fire seems to have died down recently.
Did someone set it on fire on purpose?
What happened to the neighbor's family?
Did anyone survive?
Why did they burn the house down?
Your head is filled with anxious thoughts.
And a feeling of incomprehension and helplessness!
What was that?
I just heard something.
A pale, creepy man stands on the road and smiles.
I trust Long Guy and Jack Black.
I'll be sad if they let us down.
Yeah, I trust those two also.
So...
British archaeology...
Archaeologist?
Wait...
Can eat mummy jerky but I can't sip mummy juice.
What a cruel world.
I know, right?
Oh...
He has someone's severed head in his hand.
Wearing a helmet?
Oh no!
I saw a white house and they wanted it painted black.
No colors anymore?
Yeah!
They just...
You know...
What if...
What if a lightning came from the sun?
Could've been.
It's a soldier's head with a grimace of horror frozen on his face.
You're very uncomfortable with what you see.
Yeah, because this guy's obsessed with me and once in my home.
Shirtless freak.
The entire squad of soldiers who are here were here...
The entire squad of soldiers who were here yesterday are dead.
Average Mito viewer?
No!
The bodies are strewn all over the street, and one of the bodies is missing a head!
No head?
Did that pale, creepy stranger kill them all?
You are horrified by this picture of carnage, and you feel in danger.
I'm in danger!
All right, who's here?
Oh!
I'm from the FEMA crew!
We're here to help you!
Oh!
You came alone?
How can I trust you?
You must have seen the news.
We were there.
I can also show you my ID.
Why are you wearing a hazmat suit?
Are we getting one of those?
How will you help us?
Yeah, how will you help us?
First, we have to do some investigation.
Based on the results, I will be able to take further action by notifying the management.
You will need to wait a little.
Uh, do you have an action plan?
Of course!
It's not like we can act spontaneously.
We'll take any one person with us for examining...
Since you may have been exposed to solar radiation, we'll check the health of one.
Wait, we can get rid of the girl!
She...
She'll be so happy to be able to lay on a...
On a table and get experimented on.
Based on that, we'll decide if you all need help.
It can be anyone.
Do I have to pack two?
What's next?
Wait.
Either we will evaluate you from the dangerous area, or we will bring the man back to...
No, don't bring the bag!
The rude guy!
We will issue instructions either way.
Oh!
No!
I didn't get the juice!
Now I'm taking the man from you!
No!
Jack Black!
We'll go...
No!
Goodbye!
I'm never seeing him again at our...
No!
What a mess.
Did you see that?
This guy is bugging.
Door growling is apparently a sound bug, and meant to be whispering.
Oh!
So if there's like two people in there...
Jack Black, honorable sacrifice.
He will be remembered.
Oh, so it's like if there's two people in a room...
Boom!
Did I kill that lady for no reason?
Oopsie.
What kind of society is this?
The...
I definitely read...
Not beasts.
The beasts around here are revealed.
Oh!
He took off his...
His high heels!
Finally, nobody's pretending.
He's like, I can finally reveal my real height.
Six foot two.
Are you one of the beasts?
The music...
What do you mean?
Oh!
Hey, Gru again.
Haven't you been to the other houses?
Outside on the street?
All those social norms and other crap don't work anymore.
Might makes right now.
And if you can outfight others, you've won an established order.
How many houses have you switched?
How have you survived all this time?
I haven't been anywhere for a long time.
But everywhere I see chaos.
Fear blinds people to so many things.
You still have some order.
That's interesting.
I'd like to see you keep it.
This guy is definitely the cause of the chaos.
Um...
Uh...
He looks like a businessman.
This guy is so sus.
Let him in.
This guy is pretty sus.
He's our muscle.
Come on in.
An intelligent decision.
The force now rules your life and you either accept it or get in trouble.
The heck does that mean?
Oh!
Let me in!
Are you hysterical?
Somebody don't say that to her.
Establish order by taking on and off at your heels.
Something happened?
Uh...
My daddy...
Killed my dad.
You did?
You killed your dad?
Who killed your dad?
Who did this?
We had visitors.
They sat in our room.
Daddy was...
Talking to them about something.
And then they killed him.
Uh...
Our house is...
Now on...
Fire.
How did she survive?
That's what I'm thinking.
How did she get out?
She doesn't look burnt at all.
She's just a baby.
You can check her later.
Okay.
Can you help me?
I'm scared.
I'm not from around here.
I don't like staying in one place too long.
Can't roam around as much anymore.
I'm getting too old for that.
Uh...
What are you looking for here?
In town?
I just want to rest.
After this damn sun, the visitors start popping up more.
Crawling everywhere.
What do you mean after the sun?
Were the visitors around before the sun?
Evil Jack Black.
Not everybody with a beard can be Jack Black, you guys.
Not everybody that comes to the door with a beard is Jack Black.
We did lose...
What if he's just like, I'm looking for my brother.
He looks exactly like me.
I'm telling you, we need to snuff them out.
They're trying to pull something on us.
Uh...
Do you want to kill the visitors?
Aren't you doing the same thing?
Ooh!
Or do you just tell them to shoot?
You're not stupid, right?
You kick them out, but tomorrow they'll tear you apart and won't even remember your name.
Get it?
You gotta be careful with them.
That's the thing.
I'm gonna have too many people in my home.
Eh, come on in.
I knew you weren't a pus- pushover.
A real man.
We'll mix it up with these visitors.
They won't come near us by a mile.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Anybody?
How?
Uh...
Looking for someone?
I'm not looking for anyone.
I just need a place to hide.
The whole neighborhood has been kicked out.
No one knows where to go.
So this entire complex behind you, everybody's gone.
Everybody's been kicked out?
Why does everybody keep coming to my house?
Yeah, she's got the flattest head I've ever seen.
Now I'm running around in shock, looking for a place to live.
Yeah, why did they- How many of you left?
How- Why did they kick you out?
They said there was a big sunstroke or something on our house.
Those in yellow suits kicked us out.
Somebody was grabbed, taken for tests.
Oh, someone released.
She's not lying.
Well, that sounds like what the hazmat people have done.
Where's her legs?
Oh!
Is she a VTuber?
Tell her to shoot.
Why?
What'd she do wrong?
I don't think she did any- She didn't act any different.
She didn't act weird.
She can fly.
She'll take your legs.
How much room do I have left?
I feel like I've killed all the baddies.
Ah, thanks.
Don't open the door to those yellow ones, okay?
They're gonna take us somewhere.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll be fine.
Probably.
We'll probably be fine.
I think.
I think the little girl's gonna kill somebody, if anybody.
Hopefully not us.
Oh.
Good morning, dear viewers.
This is the- Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
This is the morning news.
FEMA conti- If you didn't see what that said, it said someone was killed.
FEMA continues to identify new signs of visitors.
According to their data, attempts to photograph visitors result in severe blurring- Oh, that's a easy- Okay, severe blurring.
Oh my gosh, it's just like the ring.
Are these the devs?
This effect can only be observed with film cameras.
Unfortunately, the reasons for this phenomenon has not been determined yet.
However, FEMA urges citizens to use this new information to identify visitors.
Please stay alert and calm and avoid leaving your home during daylight hours.
Who died?
What's that?
Did he eat the- Did you eat the tall man?
Oh my god!
Do you have a question for me?
I need to check on you.
What do you want to check?
I don't like having my picture taken.
If those pictures don't end up in the trash later, I'll have to take action.
Do you understand that?
You're taking a picture of the person you're talking to.
You have- You wave the photo around to make it show up faster.
You notice that the picture seems fine, but it's being snatched out of your hands.
Give it to me.
I'll throw them out myself.
Let me check your...
Teeth.
If you attack me, I'll bite your neck with these teeth.
They're not perfect, though.
I take care of my teeth.
And those that are missing- Oh!
They are perfect?
Oh.
Let those- Those masters clench them tighter in the grave.
He's- He's a visitor.
I've been out of one of these before.
Let's see who's faster?
Wait, what are you- Where did he go?
I'm so confused!
Oh, she's purple.
I want my mama!
I need to check you, though.
Let me take your picture, little girl.
Photo?
I'm not really into pho- Photo?
Photography?
Will you show me a photo later?
We take a picture that came out blurry.
The girl ran up to you without waiting for the end of the photo shoot.
Thank you.
I didn't like it.
Don't ask me to take any more pictures.
We have so many- I forgot this guy was here in my home.
Yeah, why would she run- Oh, I didn't mean that.
Hold on.
Why would she run unless she knew that taking a photo was, like, you know, gonna make her blurry?
You know what I mean?
Yeah, let's check her hands.
And I already know how to cut my own nails already.
I'm not very good at it yet.
I- Look.
Oh, they're clean.
Look at those nails.
I cut them myself.
I did it.
But I did it.
I'm going to go sit alone.
She's a child.
You guys will not survive the zombie apocalypse.
Anybody who's just like, Mint, she's just a kid.
Okay?
She's just a kid, Minto.
Um, yeah.
Did you ever see that movie Orphan?
What if, where, it was actually a grown lady, and it's based on a true story?
Yeah!
Whoa!
Capable!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
First super chat from a perpetual lurker.
Sorry, the music stops because I have to tab out, or else I can't read it because it goes too fast.
If I want to get into Metal Gear, do I have to play the first two, or can I start at Metal Gear Solid?
No, you didn't start at Metal Gear Solid.
Thank you so much for the Alcozoo, but thank you!
Keep your eyes open.
The visitor could be any one of us.
Let me check on you.
I don't really like taking pictures.
The flash reminds me of a thunderstorm.
Makes me panic.
Wait.
No, you didn't get it.
I'm not taking pictures.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Because he refused the photo?
No, we're...
We're...
We're gonna shoot him?
Blast him?
Famous Mito Bramito Heights children.
Um...
Ah...
Hear him out.
Thanks for understanding.
You know, I don't like that stuff.
The pictures, the sudden flashes, the sounds.
I'm not interested.
I...
Okay, see, that sounds like whispering.
The guy sitting at the table is green.
Those are symptoms of steamed broccoli!
Hello, Doc.
Jack Black.
Is it this...
Wait.
Okay, I have a question.
If anybody knows.
Is the person that...
gets killed in a room...
Is it the person that's in the room...
that does the killing...
or does it not matter?
Check the lady.
Yeah, that's what I was about to do.
Oh, son.
Please don't let anyone in.
I need to check on you.
What do you want to check?
I want to take your photo.
It's been a long time since I was last photographed.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Why not?
Taking a picture.
I'm going to purposely hold still...
and wait for the moment.
It's blurry.
completely.
Why can't you see me well?
Try it.
They'll smear you too.
Sayonara!
You ate tall, man!
Yeah, we really blasted her, huh?
Sayonara!
Yeah, we really...
We really got her good.
She was so normal, yeah.
There's just...
There's nobody in here.
My room is haunted.
My room is haunted!
I mean, I did...
Oh my goodness.
I did see a ghost there earlier.
I think she's fine.
I think everybody else is fine.
This is just talking to the doctor.
Oh.
Hmm?
Is the end near?
I'd like to think not.
Humanity has faced numerous disasters, always teetering on the edge.
And each time, people have summoned the strength to keep fighting.
Even when all hope seemed lost and the end appeared imminent.
I'd like to believe that this time, too, humanity will overcome the calamity that has struck us.
What if you are the visitor and are doing the longest con ever?
Yeah.
Everyone that I kill, I do turn into jerky.
Hold on.
You know what?
I'm going to test the little girl again.
We got her hands.
We got her photo.
We can do her eyes.
You will see everything I'm thinking there?
I'll be careful what I think then.
Don't worry.
Oh.
Her eyes are fine.
Why did you look like that?
You saw...
Ooh.
There.
You.
Wah.
I want a drink.
Oh, no.
She's an alcoholic.
No!
Check Jack Black.
Oh, yeah.
Let's check him, too.
I need to check you.
Let's check.
He didn't want the photo.
Let's check his eyes.
I took a screenshot of you and showed up completely blurry.
I'm sorry you had to find out this way.
Oh, Jess.
That's obvious.
It's because I'm a ghost.
Spirit photography.
No!
It's not because I'm a visitor.
It's because I'm an actual ghost.
Hands or teeth?
I guess we can check his hands.
Let's do it.
Is that dirty?
Of course my hands will be dirty.
I go out at night and dig up these devils.
It's even easier to kill them.
Wait, what?
How do you know where to dig?
Oh.
How do you know?
He smells them.
That sounds really size.
If you're going to throw me out, put me close to these.
I'm scared.
This guy's still just cheesing.
This guy's just cheesing.
He's like, well...
Anyway.
Okay.
Little girl's going to need therapy.
I mean, that's like...
That's like every...
Yeah, that's...
That's...
Everybody is going to need therapy.
You're looking at your neighbor's house.
Only a ghostly silhouette remains.
You're devastated by what you've seen.
It seems to disturb you even more to realize that it's not the evil guests who are to blame, but the people with paranoia.
It brings you anxiety.
There's...
People are going to set fire to my house, too.
Oh my god.
What is this Mad Max out here?
You see a stake with a helmet and skull on it.
There's some black, burnt skin left on the skull.
And the teeth look like someone pulled them out.
The head has been here all day.
The whole grim display looks like a threat.
Surely left by that creepy, pale visitor.
Dead man...
I don't think we need to turn into Doomguy for...
For the rest of this.
Oh my gosh!
There is a dead man hanging suspended from a lamppost with a sign around his neck.
Oh!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
My finger slipped.
I don't know what it said.
I'm so sorry.
Looks like the poor guy was mistaken for a guest and killed in a lynching.
The thought of violence engulfing a once peaceful and quiet town breaks your heart.
Makes you long for quieter times.
You can look again, you can.
I tried before, but...
No, you can't.
I'm sorry.
It was something...
Yeah, it said...
Something that...
Whatever his sign said.
I think it says, Visitors are not welcome.
Ah, I see, I see.
Thank you, guys.
We're with the FEMA team.
We need to do a survey of your neighborhood.
Uh...
The man you took isn't enough?
Last one.
Oh, that.
The examination procedure is quite exhausting.
Right now, your man is in the rehabilitation.
After he rests, we'll bring him back right away.
Why was one not enough?
The sample is too small.
He was a pretty hefty man.
The boss first said to take one at a time.
But now we need to see...
But now we see that we need more.
So we went out again.
I think if I say no...
Oh, they're gonna...
They're gonna force.
Oh yeah, who's the boss?
Alright, if there's no other way.
Yeah, he's got a gun.
Yeah.
There's no other way.
Goodbye, Amogus!
You know what?
That's fine.
Yeah, see you later, bitch.
Yeah, who's the bitch now?
It's you!
Calling me a bitch.
I don't even know you like that.
It's all for your own safety.
Cool.
Calling me a bitch.
Oh!
What do you think of that one in the suit?
I don't know how to feel.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna tell you.
I don't trust you.
You have...
You were nipple-less.
Skinny arms, big shoulders.
He's got huge shoulders.
He's doing his job.
Alright.
These are the times, aren't they?
You've got to be careful.
Is that okay?
I'm kinda busy.
Actually, don't come back later.
Can you leave?
Yeah, sure.
I didn't think you had any trouble talking to me.
Just first.
Are you alone in the house right now?
I have other people...
Getting ready.
Do you know what you're getting ready for?
It's the last days.
Didn't they tell you?
Dogs rule the world.
Ow!
And only dogs will be here.
Have a good day.
Oh, stay.
Sorry.
Why is he so...
Can I make my mouth that straight?
It's this guy!
But what comes next is a terrible secret.
They're back.
How have you survived all this time?
That's not the problem you should be worrying about.
But thanks.
And I don't yet feel that the glaciers are going to melt anytime soon.
Looks like we're in for birds raining from the sky.
You think things will get worse?
Is there any point in thinking?
I don't think we should bother our heads with it now.
Whether...
I don't know why I've given him like this sad Mickey Mouse voice.
Whether you keep talking or hide people, it's all the same.
I have no thoughts on what to do.
Well, what should we do?
What about other people?
Why do you need this knowledge?
No matter how we've looked at others, we've got nothing but caricatures.
Oh, okay.
There's so many characters here.
Caricatures.
Characters.
Mickey's changed after Kingdom Hearts.
But I thought I heard a knock again.
I...
I heard that.
I'm not hearing things.
You heard right?
The windows.
It's time to open the...
It's time to open the door to doctors.
Mickey.
I'm not hearing things.
This is the second time.
This guy.
It was this guy right here.
This guy's freaky.
You think somebody is going to die tonight?
Will it be me?
I'm going to die tonight.
No, I'm not.
I'm going to be safe.
Everybody is fine.
Oh.
It's...
Wait.
It is no longer safe to live on the surface of the earth.
You board up all the windows and barricade the doors.
After conferring with your tenants, you decide not to go out into the outside world anymore.
You pray helplessly that somebody...
Someday, this will all be over.
If this nightmare ever ends.
At the very least, you have peace of mind knowing that there are only humans under your roof.
Yippee!
Oh, wait.
Then I did it.
Right?
So quiet.
Yeah!
Woohoo!
You win.
Nice.
Um.
Cool.
Cool!
Uh.
Come on.
Wait.
I kinda wanna let some... some bad guys into my house, though.
What if we... what if we only kill the humans and we let all the creepy people stay?
Should we do like a speedrun where we do that?
We can do a really... really fast run, you know?
I won't listen to like any of the texts, like all this we read.
Um... What's going on out there?
Better not to leave the house.
Okay.
And no one else will come tonight.
Alright.
We're just gonna... I just wanna see what's gonna happen.
Do you wanna know who are the freaks?
Oh, yeah, that would be so helpful.
Actually... yes.
Okay.
Alright.
Um... Oh, yeah, we talked to this guy in the cabinet.
Okay.
Freaks spotted in the bottom right.
They have a PO box for fan mail.
Liam, thank you for asking, but I don't.
Oh, no.
I missed a restart.
Oh, we didn't restart.
I finished... actually... I finished it.
So...
You are a freak with those pearly whites.
My teeth are...
Wait, my teeth are not perfect.
I have a fang.
My teeth are not perfect.
Let's see your hands, me too.
What's your dad's name?
Did you forget his name?
Oh, you're checking to see if I'm a visitor.
You're smart.
I'll start checking people now, too.
Yeah, I'm just gonna skip all this.
Goodbye.
Okay.
So this guy is safe.
Should we still let him in, though?
Do you think...
What if we just let in everybody?
Long boy is human.
Yeah.
I can't decide if I want to let...
Let in everyone and kill no one.
Yeah, that's what I would have to do.
Or I only let in the freaks.
I kind of want to see what happens if you only let in the freaks, you know?
I think visitors will clear out guests and then get to you last.
That's what I'm thinking will happen, too.
Let's...
Goodbye.
I understand.
Aw, I understand you.
But I'm angry.
You're just as much as a coward as everyone else here.
Sleep well at night, homeowner.
And freak you.
Dang, okay.
He did say he has a temper.
So this is a visitor.
Who are you?
What are you gonna do now?
Come on in.
You freaky...
Freak...
Quad.
Lord Freak Quad over here.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Yeah.
Okay.
We know where they are, this freakazoid freak-o.
How do you recognize a visitor?
I wish I knew how.
I'm so scared that a visitor could be anyone.
The only thing I heard on the radio was that their teeth are perfect, but...
Do regular people not have good teeth?
Heh heh.
Oh my god.
They're such a freak!
Why are you laughing?
What do you know about the cataclysm?
I don't even know what to say.
I've decided to look out the window and...
I wish I hadn't looked out there.
The sun just burned some kids.
I don't want to die from the burning sun so badly.
I'd rather die a quick and painless death than die from the sun in agony.
I don't want to be burned to death.
I don't know!
It's only going to get worse.
I know it.
We're all going to die.
I'm so...
I'm sorry.
I'm very worried.
Show me your teeth.
And then we're going to hear you out.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh.
Let's go to sleep.
Let's drink some beer.
Go to sleep.
She's a visitor.
I know.
Wait.
Are we going to die then in the night?
Let's see.
Do we die immediately?
This one was a freak too, no?
Oh, thank you so much for the rain.
Thank you.
You don't mind the heat?
I always feel cold.
While some are burning up outside, I wrap myself in jackets and still feel cold.
I'm scared to take off my clothes.
What if it only brings more suffering?
And what if I can't die from it?
Come on in.
Ceiling.
Yeah, you insulted my ceiling.
You hate my little...
My adorable home.
Oh, I have to turn him away.
Jack is back, baby.
You're scaring me.
Are you out of your mind?
Listen to me.
I'll give...
Keep him?
But he'll die.
He's going to get eaten.
It's his destiny.
I can't...
I can't turn him away.
I can't turn him...
Oh, do you need anything?
Okay.
Goodbye.
No one else will come tonight.
Alright.
So we have...
Two freaks...
In our home.
Someone was killed so fast!
Do I go?
Thank you so much for the five gifted...
No way!
Did they eat him immediately?
No.
No way!
We didn't...
We didn't even get to talk to him!
Oh my god!
I wish there was some warmth.
I need to check on you.
It wasn't her hands all messed up?
Oh yeah, that's right.
Here, out.
I'm so tired of...
You know what?
I'm so tired of living...
Wait.
In the other house, someone I...
Someone must have killed someone, I guess.
Wait, what just happened?
I...
Huh?
It was a bug?
Oh.
Why is it...
What the?
Wait!
But I clicked hear her out!
Nobody is safe.
Nobody is safe!
It's fine.
We still have another freak in here.
I'm not a monster!
I didn't do it!
I tried not to!
My finger slipped!
It's Jack Black Spirit.
Okay, let's see.
I'm the visitor, truly.
Oh!
Who are you?
How's it going?
Everything okay?
Why are you ignoring my question?
The voices!
Listen!
What if I say that I'm alone?
I wouldn't test everything!
Say you are alone?
I'm alone.
How come?
It's hard to be alone.
What's wrong with you?
Come with me, young man.
Oh!
No one will know what happened when the last guest arrived.
The house is left unoccupied for a long time.
After your terrible disappearance, everyone avoids the abandoned house.
Super.
Super!
Oh, okay.
Yeah, what if you were actually alone?
Super.
Super, I think.
Should we try again?
I guess we lost our two...
Our freak.
I just won't even...
Okay, hold on.
I'm just not even gonna...
I'm not even gonna...
Oh, what's the word?
Super.
Can I get a spooky happy birthday?
Oh, the username!
Happy birthday!
We're not even gonna check the...
People that we think are freaks.
Because...
We don't want the bug to happen.
Oh, wait.
Uh, you...
We will get eaten.
I want to be eaten.
I want to experience...
Being eaten.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I must turn you away.
I'm sorry.
You better leave.
And then he says, F you.
Okay.
You!
Come on in!
Alright.
Time to go to sleep.
Honk shoo, honk shoo.
Alright.
Drink some beer.
Go to sleep.
Alright.
Where is this?
4%?
No!
This is a real speed run though, you guys.
Will we let Jack Black in again?
He gets eaten immediately.
Don't?
Okay.
We'll let him be free.
Did you pretend you didn't know anything about the sun?
Well, F you then.
I'll save someone else.
Alright.
Bye-bye.
He's so cute.
This guy.
Okay.
No one else will come tonight.
Maybe because they were satiated by him.
That's why I didn't get eaten.
Oh.
I'm alive.
That's how...
I think that's how you know that they're both freakazoids.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
I think that's how you know.
Alright.
Let's see.
Bed!
Let's invite some more freaks inside.
Maybe we aren't tasting it, right?
Oh, this guy.
Oh, yeah.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
I'm not alone.
I...
I
thought the left option was the safe one.
I thought so, too.
I thought it was, too.
I'm technically alone.
Maybe.
Because none of them were human.
Oh, maybe.
You definitely picked the good one.
Yeah.
But I didn't get to see what he said because I clicked so fast.
Maybe he's like, No, you think you're not alone, but you are.
Ha, ha, ha.
I will, I will, I will, I will suck your blood.
Blah, blah.
It's because he only had visitors.
Ah, I see.
That's what happened.
Well.
Yeah, that's probably what he said.
I don't think we can get past that, then.
Because if we say...
That we're not alone, he still takes us.
You need to have at least one normie to progress.
I could do one more!
Where I just let in everybody.
We need to take Jug Black.
Alright, last try.
Last try.
I don't know why I'm so obsessed.
This is probably not going to be satisfying at all.
I'm so obsessed with...
I wish I could run.
I'm so obsessed with trying to get this ending.
I don't know why.
It's like...
It's like something that I must do.
I'm just...
I'm like a ghost traversing...
The same...
The same steps every day.
I don't know why I'm so obsessed.
I don't know.
Okay.
Drink our beer.
I guess I could have gone through that, but that's okay.
Alright.
Like a ghost.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
Honestly, I'm curious too.
I'm glad that we can share in our curiosity.
So we'll just let everybody in though.
It's going to be a full house.
Next person.
You.
Come on in.
Alright.
Party, party, party.
Party, party, party, party, party, party, party, party, party.
Do you have to back up from the door each time?
I don't know actually.
Oh wait.
I don't think we need to talk to anybody.
I think we can just drink our beer and sleep.
I'm feeling drowsy from the beer.
Come on in.
Let's see.
Oh, there we go.
Come on in.
I actually want to see it.
You're weird.
It's even safer that way.
For me, mostly.
But still.
It's easier to preserve something from floods, fires, and time.
Not every seed becomes a tree.
Aha.
Will you read my fortune?
Oh, but I think I did the middle paragraph.
So let's do the beginning now.
The dead will come and tell.
Oh, it's the same thing?
What is your book just...
The illusion of choice, I guess.
It was the same thing.
Thanks for the gifted kitties.
Thank you.
Who dies?
Oh.
Someone died.
Place your bets, everybody.
I think it's Tall Man.
Do you think Jack also died?
We got him.
Okay.
Let's see what he says.
Let's just talk to him.
How do you recognize a visitor?
I don't think I know the plain truth.
You ask me.
Who are the visitors?
So here I'll answer you.
They are, my hearty friend, visitors from other planets.
They are the descendants of aliens who came to Earth when the Earth Sun was younger and the grass was greener.
They planted them in the soil like sprouts of evil and they have been growing for eight years.
So specific.
Now they have crawled out and want to take our Earth.
But the Sun has decided to protect us.
For the Sun is unmilitary to visitors.
What if he's right?
I'm afraid it's been eight years.
Beep.
Otherwise, why have they been hiding underground all this time?
Freak, I wish I had a cold beer.
I got you.
I got you, buddy.
Actually, you have liver problems for real.
What do you know about the cataclysm?
A lot!
And believe me, my friend, this is far from over.
This is just the beginning.
The scale has not yet been filled enough to balance the universal powers.
It takes more to be burned in the righteous flames of the Sun.
But know, my friend, these sacrifices will not be in vain.
Someday we will all understand the true intentions of the Sun-faced One.
Freak, sometimes at night I really miss my wife.
Steve!
She was a saintly woman.
But a real piece of work.
Didn't know Chicken Jockey Guy was in this game.
Oh, yeah.
We got everything.
He misses his wife.
Peaches!
Oh my gosh!
I was talking to a friend the other day.
And I was like, how...
Like, listening to the Lava Chicken song...
It sounds almost exactly like the Peaches song.
And how much do you want to bet?
They were like, we need another song to go viral.
Like the Peaches song.
So...
Because it's like, la-la-la-la-la-ba and Peaches, Peaches, Peaches...
You know?
It's like the...
It's the same song.
How much do you want to bet?
They were like...
Is there...
Has anyone seen a Minecraft movie?
Is there anyone else?
Any other songs in that movie?
Except the Lava Chicken song.
Why are you here?
What do you want?
Listen.
I still...
Yeah, I like Peaches better.
Peach.
You're so cool.
It's so crazy also...
How like...
Everybody loved Jack Black for...
For Bowser.
But as soon as he turned...
Everybody turned on him when he became Steve.
They sang four times in the Minecraft movie.
Wait, actually?
It's just not the same.
If only it was animated.
I think that would have helped a ton.
Honestly, if it was just animated...
It would have helped so much.
Okay.
I have other people taking shelter.
You're lucky tonight.
Okay, bye.
Okay, cool.
Back to our...
Regularly scheduled programming.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm not gonna let this person in, you guys.
You.
Scary.
Oh.
Should we let in Amogus?
Let them all in.
You said...
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Never mind.
Fine, never mind.
Come on in.
Fine.
Everybody comes in.
We're already at the military, guys.
It's a party.
Who's gonna die?
I wonder who died.
At least they have the decency to clean up the bodies, you know?
Okay, you're still alive.
No.
Wait.
The doctor's still alive?
Oh my god, it's so loud.
I just put them in little baggies.
Peaches.
He didn't use creative mode.
So sad.
Oh.
Uh, you came alone?
No, of course not.
Our crew is going door to door in the neighborhood.
We're splitting up to get the job done faster.
I won't be staying long.
Are we getting a hazmat?
There's no reason to be afraid.
The suit is in case we catch the sunrise.
Civilians don't need it now.
Just stay home.
We'll take care of you.
What's next?
Okay, take a man.
Do I have to pack two?
No.
You are, as I understand it, the owner of the house.
You stay here for now.
We'll take a man away for a while, then decide what to do next.
We'll issue instructions afterwards.
Oh, there he goes!
Goodbye, muggles!
This guy was a freak.
Come on in.
Come on in, freaky.
He was normal?
No, I thought he was a freak.
Oh wait, no.
It was the lady.
It was the...
The couch lady.
The couch potato lady.
Um...
We need meat shields still.
Do we?
Bags is normal people.
Oh, when I shot him, he became a bag.
Uh...
Among Us guy is actually one of the freaks.
Is he really?
What do I do, you guys?
Are you hysterical?
I don't know what to do.
Why did they do that?
I don't know.
They were silently sitting in the kitchen.
They set fire.
While I was running, they were laughing.
The bald guy is human, but kills others.
The Among Us guy?
No way.
Guys, I don't want to take her in.
You need to.
Oh, no, the suit guy.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
You need her.
Okay.
How do you travel?
You want to kill the...
Oh, where's your weapon?
I had a gun.
I almost got myself killed.
They waited until I was asleep in the tent and stole my gun.
I was running.
They were shooting.
That's the kind of fun they have.
There's nothing human, but a shell.
Okay, come in.
Uh...
Uh, who are you?
I used to live a couple...
How many of you left?
I'm telling you, the whole house.
Somebody didn't leave on their own.
The yellows...
He grabs it like...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Come on in.
I know you're evil.
Okay.
Wait.
Uh...
Guys, I'm stuck.
Wait.
Guys?
Guys, am I...
I'm stuck.
I'm one with the wall!
Wait, what?
Oh!
Wait.
I can only...
Hold on.
Let me make sure that it's not my keyboard.
Okay.
It's not my keyboard.
Oh.
Minto timeout.
No!
Okay.
We can make this.
We can do this.
I can only walk backwards.
Somebody was killed!
Okay.
We're fine now.
Everything's fine.
Who was killed?
The doctor?
Oh.
Wait, who was killed?
There was no bodies!
The girl?
No, she's right there!
Twerks to the door.
I'm...
So confused!
Weird.
I think the girl glitched.
Maybe we can talk to her?
Oh!
I cannot talk to her.
Oh no!
Oh my god!
She's not meant to be killed, but can still be killed anyway.
But...
She's a ghost!
Just like me!
Is the end near?
I believe the end will come for us if we don't stop the visitors.
These damn beasts want to deceive us and sneak in behind our backs.
And slaughter us one by one, under cover in the night, while we sleep.
I think they might get to you sooner or later.
But that won't happen if you kill the visitors before he kills you.
Yeah.
She's dead.
You've done a lot for those who let...
Who you let in.
But too much blood has been spilled.
You are too dangerous to stay in this house!
You must leave!
You are being driven out by your own...
Driven out of your own home by people fearing for their safety.
You didn't live one day.
And burned by the scorching sun.
I didn't live a single day!
What?
It's my house!
Welp.
Um...
That's kinda funny.
It was a mutiny!
They took over my home!
Wait, what was that?
If I were to draw a fan art, am I allowed to draw mint as floating or translucent?
Yeah!
I'm a ghost!
Where else can I post mint fan art?
Ugh!
I guess...
I guess wherever you want to.
I, um...
I...
Might not see it if it's other places, but you can, you know, post wherever you want.
Difficult to catch streams, but I love you.
Thank you, soul!
Thank you!
Well, that was Sillyhand.
Yeah, there's Pixiv, there's Boosguy.
How about not letting anyone in?
I don't think we can do that because we'll just get stuck at the, uh...
The guy again.
The shirtless man.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The nippleless man.
This was fun, though.
This was silly, no?
Tall man, you were a real one.
I...
That's my biggest regret, was letting him die.
Letting tall man die was my biggest regret.
It was by that...
The girl in the jacket, no?
He was a real homie.
Jack Black was my favorite character.
This was, uh...
So there is gonna be a full version of this game.
I think it said Fall 2025, so...
Wyoming Conquest!
The name changes.
So I'm really curious where they go with the story.
If you let three people die, you get kicked out.
Aw...
I wanted to get eaten.
What's a girl gotta do to get eaten around here?
I told you we shouldn't have let the little girl in.
Jesus Christ!
Thanks for the gifted.
We showed them who the real freaks were.
Now we're homeless.
Continuing the cycle.
Why is it so hard to get eaten?
Devs will have a field day fixing bugs in this game by watching the beat of mine.
I can't believe we got stuck on the wall.
And then there was the ghost.
I need to see what the ghost was.
Wait, I'm gonna look it up.
Hold on.
No.
I'm...
Wait.
I'm not a human.
Ghost...
Oh wait, a ghost!
Ghost in the living room!
On the second day, after letting in the conspiracy guy and turning away the cold woman, I'd noticed a ghostly woman sitting on the right side armchair in the living room, who disappeared after I opened the door!
I only had the tall man in there, and I had killed the homeless woman on the same day before going in.
What...
What woman?
I haven't been able to find anything written about this anywhere.
Has anyone noticed anything like it?
Oh, there's like a...
There's like a secret...
Oh, there's secrets and easter eggs in the...
In the game.
Already?
That's crazy!
I am Steve!
Always fun to watch him in the after work!
Thank you!
Watch the trailer for a little bit of lore!
Oh, okay!
I actually did watch it...
Or...
I watched...
Kind of...
It earlier, because I was just like, These are coming out!
So...
But yeah, this is fun!
And...
I hope you guys enjoyed hanging out with me!
Eh?
Good to meet you!
Meet us!
Escort!
Is that Sakura gone?
I felt bad getting a free check-in.
So here you go!
No!
What are you talking about?
They were meant to be free!
But thank you!
Thanks for the fun stream!
Glad you could escape the wall...
Without...
I...
Have a good rest!
Thank you!
Thank you to our goal!
Um...
It's a bit of a shorter stream today...
But tomorrow I think will be longer...
And...
Sunday will be very long of a stream...
So...
Fake Nathaku!
What a weird but interesting game!
Yeah!
I am a nightmare!
Non-stop!
Mimmy nightmare!
Doom no clip codes!
Oh!
Thank you!
But um...
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I hope you guys had fun!
And I will see you when I see you next!
Sorry again for the shorter stream!
But um...
I had fun!
Sorry that we couldn't get eaten!
Maybe...
Alright!
The Super Chat!
It's okay!
I...
I can read your messages in chat!
But thank you so much!
Thank you!
Okie dokie!
Hit end!
Oh god!
Alright!
You want me gone, right?
You want me to leave?
Fine!
I understand!
You're like...
Get out of here, Minto!
Get out of here!
We don't want you...
We don't...
Earthquake!
Woooowooowwww!
Woooow!
OOOOOAAAHHH!